هو بدوره قال المندوب الصيني لدى الامم
المتحده جان جون ان مجلس الامن غير قادرا
على ايصال رساله قويه بشان القضيه
الفلسطينيه رغم مناشدات الدول الاعضاء
بالامم المتحده وحتى داخل مجلس الامن وقبل
انطلاق جلسه مشاورات مغلقه دعت اليها
الصين والامارات وفرنسا لمناقشه الاوضاع
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله قال
المندوب الصيني انه يجب على اسرائيل
الامتناع عن استخدام المزيد من العنف
وحمايه المدنيين وفقا للقانون الدولي
لقد الدول الاعضاء ولكن مجلس الامن لا
يزال غير قادرين على ايصال اي رساله قويه
خلال الاجتماعات الاخيره سمعنا مرارا من
الدول الاعضاء واعضاء المجلس يطالبون
اسرائيل بالتوقف عن اتخاذ المزيد من
الاجراءات الاستفزازيه ويطلبون منها
الامتناع عن استخدام المزيد من العنف
وممارسه سلطتها باعتبارها قوه احتلال
مسؤوله عن حمايه المدنيين بموجب القانون
الدولي لذلك نحن نتابع عن كتاب اخر
التطورات طلبه الصين من الامارات وفرنسا
اجراء مشاورات وسنستمعوا للمنسق الاموي
الخاص لكنني لست متفائلا قد ينفجر بركان
في اي وقت وقد تكون هناك عواقب اخرى نحن
بحاجه الى التفكير بجديه فيما سيحدث لاحقا